foreign
[Music]
briefing for Tuesday October 11th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
these days the number of TV streaming
services can seem endless Netflix Hulu
Disney plus Apple TV plus and on and on
and now adding to those choices are
bundle options packages of multiple
streaming or other services offered for
one monthly fee if it sounds familiar
that could be because the platforms are
taking a page out of the Playbook of the
old cable bundles but with a few key
differences here to discuss those and
why streaming Giants are taking this
route is our Deputy media editor Jessica
tunkle hi Jessica thanks for joining me
thanks for having me
so to start off why are platforms
deciding to offer these bundles so
you're seeing a few things happen here
but one of them is that over the past
three years all of the major
entertainment companies have launched
streaming services so it started with
Netflix and you had Hulu then Apple TV
plus you have HBO Max you have Paramount
plus you have peacock everyone has come
to Market with these streaming services
and now they have to really grow so
they're looking to partner up as a way
to get customers quickly can you
describe what some of these bundles look
like so the bundles are kind of coming
in different variations right so you
have the mobile phone operators like a
T-Mobile or Verizon that are offering
their own bundles so for example if
you're a subscriber of T-Mobile you can
get Netflix for free as well as Apple TV
plus and Paramount Plus for one year
then you have kind of these retailers
that are also starting to get into the
bundle game so Walmart has a program
called Walmart plus which is the
equivalent to Amazon Prime is what
they're trying to be and Walmart
recently announced a deal which we broke
with Paramount plus so if you are a
member of Walmart plus you now can get
the ad version of Paramount Plus for
free for being a member so those are the
retailers getting into it we've also
heard that Costco has started to look
into doing something similar and then
you have the tech companies that are
doing it so Amazon is known for its
Amazon Prime video channel so if you go
to Amazon Prime video channels you'll
see you can access any app on one app
and the next step of that is they're
also looking at offering pricing bundles
which means maybe you could get two
streaming services at a discount then
you would get them if you bought them
separately you mentioned you know phone
services retailers tech companies that
are all offering these bundle I guess
you know is that what makes it different
from the old cable bundles that were
maybe a little more familiar with I
think that the thing about the Cable
Bundle is that the cable you were
talking about over 100 channels right I
mean easily for well over a hundred
dollars a month and people didn't like
it because they were paying a lot of
money for a lot of things that they
weren't watching right now these bundles
are trying to be a little bit more
targeted more specific they're not
trying to be everything for everyone
they're trying to be like
hey I'm Disney ESPN plus and Hulu that's
one example of a bundle that you have
stuff for kids you have stuff for the
whole family with grown-ups and you have
sports
so they're trying to be more targeted
and specific and not trying to be all
things to all people financially how is
that shaking out for the streaming
platforms so these are pretty complex
deals to come about first of all the
platform pays the streaming service so
for example Walmart pays Paramount Plus
two to three dollars per subscriber that
actually activates their service so you
have to really make sure that each
partner is invested in what they're
doing right like you can't just like
sign a deal and hope everything goes
well the Walmart Paramount plus deal we
reported it took over a year to
negotiate each company came in with what
their marketing agenda would be what it
would look like Walmart is marketing it
in its stores if you go in you see you
know Paw Patrol and Top Gun and all of
their TVs so these are pretty complex
deals that involve various parts of the
business because the thing is when you
go into these deals you're not going to
get as much per subscribers if they were
paying full price but your hope is that
the volume will make up for that and
then if you have an ad supported service
you'll make up Revenue through them
looking at more ads and buying products
and so on what does this all mean for
customers then I think the goal for
customers is making a little bit more
simpler and hey if you can get a
streaming service for free here or there
that's great I mean right now it's not
clear that all customers know that they
can get everything you know if I spoke
to quite a few individuals who had
access to certain streaming services
through you know a T-Mobile account or
whatever it was and didn't realize they
had it so there is a concern that you
know it may cause more confusion than it
is meant to but for the Savvy consumers
who seek out these bundles you can get
some good deals so kind of thinking
forward this kind of great rebundling
offering all these different monthly
services that we have options to what
does it mean for for streaming going
forward is it a sign that maybe it's
going to be a market that's shrinking or
consolidating I think this partnership
mentality that you're seeing now where
everyone's kind of looking for a dance
partner is kind of like I'd like to
think of it as like the second phase of
the streaming Wars the first phase was
everyone launching now it's like
everyone partnering and bundling and
figuring out who their dance partner is
going to be and then the third phase
will be M A where you'll see companies
start buying other companies there's a
lot of reasons that's not happening
right now the regulatory environment the
markets so Partnerships make sense and
what's a better way to figure out if you
should engage in merger talks with
someone than to partner with them
all right so phase two of the streaming
Wars Jessica tunkel our Deputy media
editor thanks so much for joining us
thanks for having me and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]